hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I'm your host
Mark Ellis Jacqueline Coley taking a
break maybe playing video games she's
probably working on some sort of
undercover assignment but again we just
had award season so she is now in her
Blissful post-award season I would say
relaxation state but again knowing her
she's probably banging away at some
keyboard writing some article that
you're going to get to see on
rottentomatoes.com speaking of articles
on rottentomatoes.com that happens to be
the subject of our chat here today I
can't do it alone I can barely function
so we have two of our Primo guests here
joining us in studio first of all you
know there's one third of the World
Girls you also know her as the star uh
films like always Lola which just made a
great award circuit run and she's just
about to enter into a new project that
might take her away from us for a little
bit so Roxy before you go off filming
another one I am pleased to welcome from
you back it's Roxy stryer to Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong yeah I may know a
thing about movie quotes now that I've
been in a couple listen some street cred
going on right now on that Silver Screen
and that is what we're talking about
today is the most memorable movie quotes
of all time but we're gonna focus on
Rotten Tomatoes celebrating his 25th
birthday so we're gonna set we're going
to focus on the 98 on so anything from
the late 90s on and although this young
man loves quoting his movie release
dates as far back as the late 70s early
80s he also is known for his love of
movie quotes he is the one the only you
see him on this on TV all the time
National TV he's a legend here we're
doing local stuff like KTLA you see him
pop in a lot radio red carpets q and A's
the man does it all and he is the man's
man Scott mans Mark Roxy I had been and
always shall be your friends
oh there you go already
I should have done that introduce me
second next time yeah I should have
given you that that soft ramp up but I
mean like you've been on set a lot
recently Scott you've been talking I
mean you're probably blowing the face
talking about award season kind of
movies too and so now we're just getting
back into the summer season that we're
looking ahead maybe we get some more
memorable movie quotes from movies this
summer like in Indiana Jones five I
think we know the one word quote we're
gonna get from fast 10 which is just
gonna be family
oh that's a good warm-up one but we have
on rottentomatoes.com the most memorable
movie lines of the last 25 years uh it
was curated by our staff here and look
anybody is going to have some sort of
issue with this list where it's like oh
how are you going to take that movie
quote over this one oh you forgot about
this movie or even you got the movie
right you just necessarily didn't get
the quote from the movie right there's
better quotes in that and I already see
my guest smile looking to talk about it
so you can click on the link in our
description this podcast if that's how
you're getting it but you can just go to
rottentomatoes.com and check out the
most memorable movie lines of the last
25 years since we were born here at RT
hard to believe it's been 25 years ago
well here's the fun is that technically
Rotten Tomatoes was started in August so
our producer Brian Perez he comes in and
I just know he's got some good news
right maybe something happened in his
personal life this weekend maybe he's
just excited about doing this episode he
comes up to me and he's like okay so
it's from August 98 on and I'm like okay
and he's like which means we can include
rush hour because power came out in
September of 98. so rush hour is
eligible to be mentioned but I don't
want to leave into just that we are
going to have some time to talk about
our all-time favorite movie quotes from
any era but let's start here because we
always ask our guests if we're talking
about a movie or a TV series is it
fresher rotten is Rotten Tomatoes right
or wrong so comments I'm going to start
with you you look at this list and you
brought a number of examples from home
your list yes is I'm sure infallible the
rottentomatoes.com list of the 25 most
memorable movie lines of the last 25
years is it fresh or rotten I gotta say
Mark it's pretty fresh there were a
couple of movies where you got the movie
right but the quote wrong and I'm
looking at Roxy going you know nodding
and we're going like yeah that's so true
but for the most part the movies you
picked and the quotes you picked from
them were very fresh okay so we got
again that's an understood you I didn't
answer necessarily do any of this stuff
I'm just looking at the list and writing
it right along with you and Roxy take
the credit Mark take the credit again
you were up endless nights working on
this list I know I mean you got to watch
some of the best movies of the last 25
years so in Roxy striers not so humble
opinion is Rotten Tomatoes fresh or
rotten with this list so I wanted to go
in with fresh eyes so instead of looking
at the list first I made a list before I
looked at the list to see how my list
would kind of Stack Up I did more like a
15 just to see if it was going to be on
there and then I went and looked and
they were almost all on there there you
go I was like okay that's how you know
this was done very well because it
matches my opinion which is the least
important opinion at this table but
still matters it was very good a woman
of the people I'm just it was so fun
watching you all talk pre-show because
all y'all wanted to talk about was TV
shows so it's just nice getting that out
of the way while TV is where it's at I
mean like looking all the quality on all
the streaming services all these shows
that you like gotta binge or you got to
watch at midnight when it drops because
you wake up and then you go on you you
know go on the internet and just it's
totally spoiled so but I mean just know
exactly what you're talking about there
was a big spoiler this past week oh no
you didn't Roxy strior didn't catch a TV
show on time I did I just saw the rest
of the people get spoiled about
succession you didn't see oh well that's
why I bring up the streaming just for a
minute is because which shows like
succession or a lot of the the quality
stuff that we got in all these various
streaming platforms now it's you look at
this list of 25 movie lines most of them
were from like the late 90s early 2000s
not a lot of movie quotes from the last
10 years of Cinema on here so you know
we have our entertainment options but
I'd like to see more quotes in more
quality films and hopefully this summer
can start to rectify that you know Mark
the the fact that you have so many
quotes from a particular year is it just
points out how great that year actually
was for movies we'll get into that
pretty quickly when we go to go through
these quotes of chronological order but
as I was going through the list I'm
going wow this year again again again
and I'm thinking like wow this year was
great and look what happened over the
last couple years you know movie going
was really uh in deep deep trouble you
know we didn't get a lot of movies over
the last couple years but now with 2023
I think they're really bouncing back and
I think 23 when we get through the end
of the year we're gonna have a lot of
great quotes do you guys believe that
you can't have a most memorable movie
quote without the movie being great you
just said that the the year had such
great movies but do you guys think it
has to be a great movie in order to have
a memorable quote that is a great
question and I would say not at all I
think you can be a garbage movie but
still have a quote that sticks out there
and just write the cream Rises to the
tops God uh I agree with that because
there's a couple movie quotes on here
from movies that are garbage we'll get
to that too let's get to it all right
now as we hit the music for movie talk
[Music]
our buddy Tim Ryan he's on the bench
this week because like we're trying to
figure out what can Tim do for us like
because he usually gives us what the
critics were saying at the time of the
movie's release and that sort of kicks
off our conversation all these movies I
don't know that Tim has the time he's a
busy guy to give us what the critics
thought about office space and then
Notting Hill and then legally but then
training day just some of the movies
that we're going to be running down on
this list I'll give you a couple more
and just as far as the movies that we
might be covering from the last 25 years
your Gladiators in there Finding Nemo's
in there more MCU movies than I thought
black panther made it in there Avengers
end game made it in there and so what
are the quotes going to be from
something like Lord of the Rings that's
what we're here to talk about now we are
going to kick off in somewhat
chronological order okay but before we
get there movie quotes in general this
guy do you remember the first movie
quote that really hit you and you're
like you're a viewer maybe you're you're
a yout you're a teenager and you're just
saying oh that that really made this
movie Stand Out that is what I'm taking
from this flick are you kidding me
asking me that question mark Ellis I bet
we're getting a release date as well you
are going to love this answer being the
massive fan that you are on May 25th
1977. sitting on my dad's lap hearing
the words May the force be with you
absolutely as an eight-year-old kid that
was like Prime spy just when movies when
Hollywood was completely changing after
jaws with Close Encounters around the
corner but without I mean it's it's a
cliche answer but because of how old I
was when I saw Star Wars when Star Wars
was called Star Wars A New Hope episode
four blah blah blah but May the force be
with you everyone for the next couple of
years through 1983 everyone was quoting
May the force be with you that's right
and I have a bad feeling about this you
never have a bad feeling when Roxy's on
the show so Roxy do you remember member
in your movie going career like that
first quote that really leapt out at you
I think I was an arrogant little kid and
so because of that I liked going to
school to talk about the movies my
parents let me watch any movie that I
want so I remember going in with the
frankly my dear I don't give a damn
quote very very young and having none of
the kids understand what I was talking
about me thinking I am so mature oh wow
good one I know something none of you
know yes you do and the history behind
it so things like that or you know
Classics from like uh Wizard of Oz or
anything that was like just the old
school movies that my parents had me
watch as a child yeah the wizard of
those movies were 1939 by the way Wizard
of Oz
and Mr Smith Goes to Washington
good good year for movies good year for
movie quotes those two usually go hand
in hand if I to up and I just say best
movie quote what's your favorite movie
quote of all time you go first Roxy it
might be there's no place like home I I
don't know yeah it's pretty good like is
that the best quote from Wizard of Oz
because the first thing I think of
Wizard of Oz is not my favorite quote
from it but the thing that stands out
just because it's got to make the other
ones feel so awkward is when Dorothy
says I'll miss you most of all scarecrow
it's like 10 man in London like right
there like okay well I I I'll take my
things and go home probably the most
memorable is lions and tigers and bears
oh my there you go yeah that's probably
the most memorable uh and then how do
you like them apples that's gotta be my
favorite for me
I honestly feel like it should have been
on the list it's very quotable very
close very 97 we're right at the cost oh
that's that's why otherwise I would have
been there yeah can I tell you something
Roxy it's not your fault
it's another good one I got it raisedly
it's pretty good uh Scott okay this is a
big build up now your all-time favorite
movie quote for the movie Man movie
quotes my goodness I mean
well I mean look May the force be with
you just because it is such a great
quote but also are you coming across to
my side of the aisle here because of
these Star Trek Star Wars skirmishes
online every so often so are you coming
over and saying Star Wars is more
quotable than Star Trek coexist I can
love them both but still Star Trek is my
favorite a little bit long and prosper
live long and prosper but that's from
the TV show okay uh what I like about
the movie is I have been and always
shall be your friend
Star Trek 2 but I also love and you know
these are not the obvious quotes I love
that you're going like real classic old
school you know mine mine aren't that
old like I love keep your friends close
and your enemies closer from Godfather
Part Two uh John Maguire is one of my
favorite movies from 1996. you complete
me I mean you gotta love that yeah but
the one that I quote a lot especially
when someone tries to pull a fast one on
me is from 1984's Indiana Jones and the
Temple of Doom someone tries to pull a
fast one on me I go nice try Lashay
we love our Quotes no time for love Dr
Jones I think that his quote Indiana
Jones is a very quotable dude I don't
know if he realizes this but the I'm
making this up as I go along was one of
my senior quotes they gave us two to
have and both of mine were from
lucasfilm Productions you could probably
guess it maybe you can't though because
Star Wars is very quotable so my other
high school movie quote that was not I'm
making this up as I go along which I
still am in my life and career is from a
movie it's from Empire Strikes Back you
do what is it you have to guess I'm your
father
I'm your father Mark Ellis I am your
father that is a great quote it's an
all-time quote what a yearbook quote
that would be maybe the best spoiler of
all time yeah I mean there's there's
certain places where that could be a
yearbook quote that is incorrect Roxy
want to take a step I don't know I don't
know I love you I know what did you say
it's from from a little girl green
Muppet oh Kermit's grandfather uh that
would be Kermit the Frog related to Yoda
who said do or do not there is no
trouble oh that's a great one It's Not
Easy Being Green Man but still it still
works yeah I am your father yeah well
you know I mean that moment I mean look
when you have it here's the thing one of
the things that makes a movie quilt
great is when it is spoofed and reused
out of context in other movies so when
you go back and watch the movie where it
actually came from you go oh okay like I
had never seen Casablanca until like the
the late 90s and I saw it at the new art
and
you know uh I think this is the
beginning of a beautiful friendship
we'll always have Paris you know some of
these lines were used in so many other
films and TV shows that when you see
them in the original context you go wow
like that that was a big deal so so when
I see Tommy Boy and you see Chris Farley
talking to the fan going Luke Luke I am
your father you know that makes that
movie quote great because it was reused
in another film yeah it's baseball
spoofing it Casablanca is interesting
Casablanca might be the most quotable
film of all time and I say that
partially because it is so good and the
writing is so well done that people
quote it thinking they're quoting the
movie and they're not even the title of
the play Play It Again Sam it's not
actually said in the movie It's inferred
play it Sam but Play It Again Sam so a
lot of times you have these movies that
are just so iconic you kind of forget
where that quote originated from the one
that is maybe more over quoted than
anything else for me as a sports fan is
when you're watching a game minutes late
say Tom Brady's got the ball two minutes
to go right or if your team is on the
bubble trying to get it in the playoffs
they will not hesitate to use the Dumb
and Dumber quote so you're telling me
there's a chance yeah yeah and it's so
overused now but in the original context
of the film still works out of Aspen I
don't know man the French are
I feel like none of us mentioning Rocky
being so quotable too yeah that's a
really good one or you're killing me
Smalls that's one that people use in
their daily life yeah totally someone
used that on me the other day and I went
oh you're Chris uh uh from uh KTLA used
me on the air I said are you quoting the
sand line and they don't even know that
they don't even know
everybody at any time your quote from a
film makes it onto a Target shirt you
can buy it at Target there's like three
different sand watch shirts you can buy
at Target so Sandlot has clearly passed
the litmus test to get into the Lexicon
still all these many years later before
we get into the 90s I got one more
question for you yep is there a
particular genre of movies that lends
themselves to being more quotable than
anything else Roxy got a big smile yeah
because Mark this is exactly the
conversation I had with myself last
night it looked really good in front of
the mirror comedies are so much more
quotable than dramas to me because I use
them more often like you it it's so
light and they make it it makes you
funnier to be able to use the quote like
if you're quoting a drama in a dinner
conversation you're kind of pompous but
if you say something that comes from an
Anchorman or a step brothers or whatever
then it's fun and everybody kind of
gives a giggle so I know that's a very
broad genre but comedies to me are very
cool yeah I agree with that Scott
because comedies you can be funny you're
expected to be funny throughout the
entire film and any sort of punch line
usually comes with a quote with dramas
it's all about that build up like Empire
Strikes Back a lot of great quotes along
the way but we're all building up to
this climactic scene Godfather 2. we're
all building up to this one thing where
it's like oh here's the setup drum roll
please boom stick your line and then
you're out but with comedies every 5 10
15 20 seconds you have an opportunity
for something else memorable I agree on
all points but when he asks you that
question of Roxanne you smiled that was
not the answer I thought you were going
to give all right what'd you think I
thought you were going to say sci-fi
hmm yeah sci-fi too and that was part of
my mirror conversation as well yeah
definitely because like we talked about
I mean also just nerdum in general when
it comes to Star Trek and Star Wars or
the MCU movies
um DC movies not as much on the list I
understand why but those those movies
were like we watched them so many times
especially as a kid the other uh
category that I thought was so quotable
is animated animated movies there's
usually one line I have a hard time
knowing what's a quote and what's kind
of like a catchphrase a lot of the
animated movies have two word quotes and
it's the name of a song but they say it
throughout like a Hakuna Matata right
like is that a quote from Lion King or
is that I would give that the quote the
night of approval I would say I mean
look we have some two like for instance
on our list of of the 98 movies on like
what I think should be on there is
Avengers Assemble should be on
and then you also have like office space
can just be hey Peter
the quote we have here is looks like
somebody asked the case of the Mondays
which is another great quote from a very
quotable movie Office Space but then you
also have like Black Panther and it's
just wakanda forever it's like two words
but they mean a whole lot you know but
the thing with the thing with office
space was it was a box office bomb so
it's written it directed by Mike Judge
who was famous for Beavis and Butthead
the movie only made 11 million dollars
when it came out in 1999 but look at how
often office space is quoted and you
know looks like you got a case of the
Monday somebody's got a case of the
Mondays that is another quote that got
picked up and is or used out of context
by people who don't realize where it
came from curtain offices every Monday
to this very day I was at Starbucks a
few weeks ago and it was a Monday and a
lot of cases of the Mondays early
morning it started oh yeah from people
who are still in line who have not yet
had their coffee I think you get to the
front and you know the guy was like what
do you want and I like totally forgot
what I was going to get even though I
get the same thing all the time and it
goes oh looks like you got a kiss of
Mondays and I'm like you know he looked
like he was like 15. yeah he has no idea
I'm like I'm just going to embarrass
like do you know where that came from do
you know the movie from Scott you know
do you know what it means to want to
have your red stapler do you know what
this means means do you know what
Michael Buck do you know who Michael
Bolton really is and I'm not talking
about the the singer you know talking
about Michael Bolton yeah I'm off his
face do you know what a TPS report is
and how to format them properly oh my
God every time someone says like like
you know if I'm in a situation and
somebody says oh don't forget to do this
and then someone said oh you know don't
forget to do this I'm like okay fine
I'll I remember about the TPS reports
but the beauty is when they know what
that what that's come from yeah they go
oh office space and you're like okay
yeah we're friends again that office
space uh did that bug bite you as hard
as it bit uh me and my friends in
college rock yeah but I was just not in
college you were not in college yet
you're much much many weeks younger than
I but office space is just one of those
movies where if you ever had had to work
a job it doesn't even necessarily have
to be in an office just a job where you
thought maybe there was something better
on the horizon for you you start
thinking about all these quotes that in
office space it seems like and again the
case of the Mondays thing comes from the
people who are annoying or protect
against Peter Gibbon so it's not even
like the heroes saying any of this stuff
it's just like that is the vibe at that
office so the Bobs always get me as far
as like the most quotable in that movie
when they say what is it you do here
those kind of things just I I re-quote
them to myself so many times in life
we're looking at our list now and we
have five movies from 1999. exactly
alone so those are office space The
Matrix Notting Hill the sixth sense and
Fight Club Roxy star which one of these
five quotes speaks to you and your heart
you know the
think you can't have a list of 25
memorable movie lines the last 25 years
and not include of these is I see dead
people which is so strange because it's
the least quotable of them like not
often in life am I walking around but
yeah
you know because that will get you in a
little bit of trouble but if you don't
have that on this list then you're not
an okay list because it is if you say I
see dead people everybody knows what
you're talking about everybody everyone
knows the success yeah everybody knows
and it's it's the only quote from that
movie that's memorable I think it's a
great movie but it's when you say that
it's like everybody stops and knows
exactly what you're talking about yeah
and the thing about that Scott to our
Point earlier about genres and which
genres the most quotable it's an
all-time quote that everybody knows
you're talking about the Sixth Sense
they know the scene you're talking about
but it takes so long for us to build up
to that it's not an indication of how
bad the movie's great but comedies it's
like every 20 seconds you get it you get
an opportunity for something like that
Sixth Sense had one chance and hit it
out of the same what makes that that
line those four words so crucial is when
it was actually said in the film first
of all I agree with you completely I see
dead people
it sums up exactly what the Sixth Sense
is all about that's the movie right
there and Haley Joel Osmond who was
nominated for supporting actor and lost
to Michael Kane for The Cider House
Rules when he looks at Bruce Willis and
says I see dead people I'm looking at
you and Bruce Willis's reaction's so
good okay all of our reactions at home
which is no I mean that was the first
time I ever saw a movie and I was like
movies can do this I feel Bamboozled but
what makes the life great to me what
makes the line great is that it was the
midpoint of the film you talk about the
build up of that movie writer director
Emma chamelan he used that moment in the
hospital when when Cole says to Bruce
Willis's character I see dead people
that was the midpoint of the film in the
hands of any other writer director that
would have been in the First Act that
would have been your inciting it opens
the movie because we we see that in the
trailer and we're kind of waiting for it
but now
this buildup that works so much better
when the line is actually hit and we
look at that I mean again five quotes
from 99 and then we have one from 2000
which is a gladiator obviously which a
number of quotes you can pull from that
one you want me to perform it for you or
no do it
entertained that moment in Gladiator
which came out it was a summer film May
of 2000. you know they're doing a sequel
to that rocks you might have a job
honestly that was my audition wait
Ridley Scott directed the hell out of
that movie and I'll tell you that moment
that moment when he says are you not
entertained is the moment that made
Russell Crowe a star I agree with you
yeah completely when you think of him
and you think about his rise to stardom
that is the moment that you think of you
everybody can kind of hear his voice I
mean mostly because I just did it for
all in your head like you hear him say
it when you read it and anytime I've
seen that like sometimes people will say
that
um and again not know where it's coming
from but I hear it like him when you see
are you not entertained you read that
it's in his voice and every wide
receiver in every shooting guard in the
pros saw that line and it was like I'm
saying that when I score a touchdown or
after I hit the big shot to win the game
like I'm saying are you not entertained
my favorite quote from Gladiator is
actually what we do in life echoes in
eternity I think that's just such a you
know he's saying that to his troops to
pair him up for for battle I can say
that to myself to go for my max bench
press you know at least at my signal
only there's so many lines in that movie
that work but Scott we were talking
about how this this list feels like it's
weighted way more towards like 99 2001
2001 has three movies Training Day
Legally Blonde and the Fast and the
Furious why is it that we have these
kind of clusters of years in your
opinion you know every once in a while
you just have a year that's totally
knocks it out of the park you have 1982
was an amazing year because you had
movies like Wrath of Khan uh Poltergeist
E.T Blade Runner the thing that was just
in the month of June of 1982. you just
had these years that just are great and
99 maybe it was all this like you know
build up to like why why 2K hysteria in
case we don't get any more movies right
like this is it right but 99 had the
Matrix it had like uh election Eyes Wide
Shut The Sixth Sense uh The Insider
American Beauty three kings keep going
you'll find it keep going right uh you
got uh
the suffering
also Being John Malkovich uh 99 was just
like a like crazy insane year and that's
why like when I was going through your
list I was like oh another one from 99
another one 2001 also a great year uh uh
but 99 was I think
the the last great year that's up there
with we were talking about 1939 it's up
there with that year you think 39 the
next great year is 99 100 wow one big
gap there that's a big gap but in terms
of just like there were so many great
movies like one movie after another you
know 80. from unexpected places I mean
nobody knew the Blair Witch Project was
coming out and then all of a sudden that
was the that was the Phenom I can't
quote Blair Witch because the only
quarter remembering Blair Witch is the
one guy stumbling around the woods
bitching about the fact that he's gonna
miss Cal Ripken breaking Lou Gehrig's
record because he's stuck out here in
the woods for the rest of the time
um I guess there's I'm so scared from
Blair Witch Project it's like it's not
bubble coming out and you just feel oh
man it is not fun to go camping in the
woods of burkinsville Maryland yeah but
when people say I'm so scared you don't
assume that they're quoting Blair Witch
yeah it's not like my friend text you I
see dead people it's okay right yeah I'm
so scared that's like you might want to
follow up with your parents next time I
text you that I'm so sorry
no no hello as we matriculate a little
further on the list we have some 2003
gems and Finding Nemo it's just keep
swimming and then the Lord of the Rings
Return of the King it's sort of what the
Oscars did with Lord of the Rings where
they give return to the king all the all
the flowers Return of the King gets the
credit for my pressure I got you
um
precious that is great what's
interesting is that's her exact same
voice for yoga it is so it works
better watch especially I'm really using
this I'm getting all that account out of
this today with my auditions
yeah for sure I've worked really hard on
that one three the three back-to-back
movies those Lord of the Rings movies
that people forget how groundbreaking
that was when new line filmed all those
movies at the same time back to back you
know outside of like reshoots and so on
but then when you get to Return of the
King in 2003 nominated for 11 Academy
Awards and it won all 11 Oscars that it
was nominated for including best picture
it bat a thousand I mean that was like
insane but out of that whole trilogy
what you have is those words my precious
another line that is quoted in other
films you know spoofing yes Return of
the King is there another quote from any
of the Lord of the Ring movies that you
guys off the top of your head you're
like oh this one I go with it you know
what I usually say to Molly the Wonder
Dog is she's outside for too long I have
to stand in front of her and I just say
you shall not pass so the the Gandalf
that's from the Bible though maybe
Jay I might have lifted a couple things
from from the good book but yeah I mean
you shall not pass is the only other one
that I think gets close to that as far
as like Lord of the Rings but my
precious it just it tells you oh we're
it's this ring and people are really big
fans of it so everybody's gonna be
feeling that way the closer they get to
the ring maybe they're like golemen it's
a slow build maybe it's like Bilbo and
they just freak out but you gotta
destroy this ring and that's basically
what we're summing up there and if if we
look at go back to genres I find that
romance particularly romantic comedies
like Notting Hill is a great example
another movie from 99 where you know I'm
just a girl in front of a boy then we
get to Brokeback Mountain which is just
you know it's a romantic movie but it's
also more of a heartbreaking romantic
movie I wish I knew how to quit you was
everywhere when that movie came out all
right so first of all here's what I
gotta say about Brokeback Mountain 2005
that movie Lost best picture can you
tell me where who lost best picture too
was that the crash here that was the
crash here
I was like oh I don't think Scott was a
fan of the film that won yeah I asked
the question that you can answer it
feels like it's like the best feeling
it's like somebody give me a sticker or
something but a great job okay I wish I
knew how to quit you what a line what a
line set by Jake Gyllenhaal's character
in that film and like the line became
such a such a like a a trademark of that
film kind of like I'm king of the world
when James Cameron collected his Oscar
for Titanic he says I'm king of the
world of course that like he got a lot
of backlash for that but in the case of
Brokeback Mountain when Ang Lee went to
the podium to collect his Oscar for best
director it all it already won a couple
of other Awards including best adapted
screenplay and Ang Lee when he was
collecting his Awards said I wish I knew
how to quit you fortunately he spoke too
soon because the audience did quit him
when they chose crash as best picture
but that film such a landmark film
and uh it may have like 178 million
dollars worldwide so really like broke a
ceiling for for like a a gay
relationship in a feature film and part
of that I I would attribute to the power
of the writing and particularly that
quote where it it puts you in in the
boots so to say it puts you where you
where this movie is putting this
relationship and it's just these two
guys who are just so they're they're so
attracted and they're just trying to
fight it yeah because that's the way
they were brought up and I think that
was a lot of society probably even as
far as the academy voters go where it's
like let's go with the safer movie
ironically the safer movie is called
crash but that's what they felt at the
time I think the test of time leans
heavily in favor of Brokeback Mountain
yeah absolutely I mean you think about
these epic love stories like um The
Notebook it's not over wasn't over it
still isn't over these lines in there a
lot of them are more monologues and
these movies where it's like you know
you're really professing your love even
in something like a Goodwill Hunting
where he's talking about his ex
everybody's painting these beautiful
pictures but this I wish I knew how to
quit you it's succinct and we can all
kind of like grasp onto that and also
unbelievably relatable yeah it's honest
it's not flowery it's not like I I wrote
you this poem right to express how much
I love you it's just Bare Bones let's
get down to it I wish I knew how to quit
you on top of everything on top of the
points that you both made it's the line
that describes exactly what this movie
is just like I see dead people is
encapsulates the sixth sense I wish I
knew how to quit you encapsulates
brokeback man like you have a line you
know because we're you were quoting uh
Google hunting you know how to how about
them apples you know how do you like
them apples I mean that doesn't really
say what the film is you know or a nice
trailer it's still a great movie right
it's still a great movie absolutely oh
if I get a lady's number or she starts
following me on Instagram at my behest
it's I'm I'm saying the one he says at
the end I gotta go see about a girl
right oh yeah yeah see that's a great
line too
that's that's the movie and look I wish
I knew how to quit you sums up that film
just like I'm just a girl standing in
front of a boy asking him to love her
from Notting Hill sure which by the way
came out the week after Star Wars
episode one The Phantom Menace and it
still became a huge box office hit but
flowers made more money that weekend
um actually but Julia Roberts
yeah I was camping out for weeks I
remember that is what I'll tell my niece
and nephew I showed up that morning got
tickets and then I went back home took a
nap then I went back to the theater on
Thursday night but you still have to
make it seem more dramatic I went for
that midnight showing at the Village
Theater in Westwood you know everybody
was so puffed so excited then the
movie's over people walked out and were
speechless I got a story about the
opening of phantom menace I might tell
on one of our After Dark episodes coming
up but I want to move on here too Roxy
uh kind of teed us up with a great
question at the beginning of the show
where it's like are there great quotes
from bad movies is that a possibility
and I think not only is this a quote
from maybe not the freshest movie of all
time but it also may be better than any
movie quote ever has in the history of
movie quotes tells you exactly what this
movie is better than I see dead people
better than I wish I knew how to quit
you Snakes on a Plane I've had it with
these mother effing snakes on this
mother effing plane if you don't know
what the movie is from that line you
should not be in that theater yeah and
so had the whole audience everybody had
had it with the snakes on the plane at
that point for sure there are quotes
like this sometimes where it's just like
I don't know why that kind of made
everybody in society laugh but it did
that just kind of it stuck with people
it's it's a situation that very very few
people have ever been in where you're on
a plane and a snake gets loose I might
say none almost none a lot of us said no
it's happened before and I've read
articles about it it's fast dating but
if you have a plane that we that most
people have been on at some point and
most people know what a snake is so and
most people are afraid of snakes like
I'm terrified of snakes I respect them
as wonderful creatures think they're
awesome I'm fascinated horrified by
snakes if we're all scared of snakes is
it because they don't have shoulders
Indiana Jones
either I don't
know if it's the invertebrate thing the
way they slithered the way that they're
I don't it's something about it the
Slime it is I don't know what it is but
snakes scare the crap out of me so
Snakes on a Plane the perfect premise
I'm gonna fast forward a couple more
years to take and in 2008 because if
there's a line you can put in a trailer
I would put this up there with I see
dead people or the the mother F and
snakes is when Liam Neeson is on the
phone we saw like the trailer for taken
again you got to remember back in 2008
this is just the very beginning of the
middle age guys still an action star
Renaissance yeah that Liam Neeson and
Bruce Wilson Denzel Washington folks
like that would Pioneer Liam Neeson on
the phone in that voice that only he can
do sounding like Aslan the lion saying I
have a very particular set of skills
yeah everybody that trailer is the
reason why taken became the first huge
hit of 2008. uh taken first of all Liam
Neeson remade taken many times even when
the film was not actually called tape
not as quotable as that first one but
yes you know some of the some of of the
things that we have to remember about
these great lines from whether the last
25 years or even before that is
sometimes a great movie line is
something that isn't even scripted
something that is improvised like Denzel
Washington in Training Day where he won
his second Academy Award when he says at
the end of the film King Kong ain't got
on me I mean that line is basically
Alonso saying I'm above the law and them
realizing he's not but that line was
improvised by Denzel Washington I think
you have a line like uh I've had enough
of these mother reference names mother F
and plane let me run down the last 10
years for you which again they're a
little lean in terms of all-time movie
quotes So from 2012 I'll skirt that
movie and they're just under the wire
but the Hunger Games is I volunteers
tribute I get it it doesn't really stand
out to me it's a it's an important scene
in the movie but it doesn't really do it
to me does it
talk about quotes that embody the entire
movie sure I volunteer as tribute it's
the whole film imagine doing that yeah
The Bravery of it all like oh my gosh
May the odds ever be in your favor
but what the movies they're May the
force be with you what it's about is
volunteering as tribute and anybody
who's been us if you love your sibling
the way that I love my siblings in that
moment of I volunteer as tribute it's
like yeah I mean what yeah yeah of
course you do that's what you do like
and nobody's done it that's a great
quote you guys are missing out I stand
correct I stand corrected with you and
but I do think that meant the odds
forever being your favorite yeah that's
that's the that's like the more the
force be with you with The Hunger Games
then we have 2017 get out now you're in
the sunken Place black panther wakanda
forever Avengers end game I love you
3000 and then from last year our Oscar
winner for best picture everything
everywhere all at once so even though
you've broken my heart yet again I
wanted to say in another life I would
have really liked just doing laundry and
taxes with you and I feel the tears
welling up in me already so those are
that kind of rounds out r25 is there
another movie that you feel like looking
at this whole list the 25 most memorable
movie lines of the last 25 years is
there a movie or maybe two or maybe 10
that you feel like got shortchanged and
was not in this list that you would swap
something out with Roxy I feel like you
are already prepared to answer this
because of the way you did your research
for the show I mean talk about pages on
pages
you know there are several it's very
hard to always narrow it down I feel
like some really quotable movies
um Borat like
I mean like if you see if I see very
nice I say it like or at and that that's
so weird everybody was my wife come on
like every time somebody's like oh my
wife's at home I said my wife like they
could be telling something very serious
and I can't not do that an unbelievably
quotable movie
um all of those movies Anchorman Step
Brothers all of the comedies yeah we do
have on the list it's not the quote that
I would have used it's a classy Stay
classy San Diego whatever even better
Scott's got Scotch down in my belly yeah
totally very quotable I think we went
with the uh what was it the Sex Panther
one it was uh yeah sixty percent of the
time it works every time for me with the
first anchor man it's I'm trapped in a
glass case of emotion that's what I
would yell more than anything else yeah
yeah I think that you're The Rare Breed
that that's the one that you're yelling
but I totally get it I feel like we
messed up the Mean Girls quote it's
Gotta Be You can't sit with us like you
can't sit with us come on I was going
Tuesdays are for or we wear pink on
Wednesdays I can't remember which day
they wear pink it's obviously Wednesdays
it's obviously Wednesdays
that you can't wear your hair in a
ponytail oh boy this is on the list but
I literally was going through the
drive-through in and out the other day
and I got a burger fries and a chocolate
shake and I got the food and I just I
don't know this is before I even got
asked to do the show I took the
milkshake and I went I said to the
person I said I drink their milkshake I
drink it up at first staring at me like
what the f there's nothing worse than
when you quote something and the person
doesn't understand and you're like
anyway he went There Will Be Blood on
the in and out drive through they did
not what about I am the captain now
all the time it's not that quotable of a
movie but that one that Line's great I'm
the captain now is great I have two from
um other sort of like populist movies
where it's these huge Blockbusters again
one of them not necessarily the best
people love Spider-Man Sam Ramy
Spiderman it's a great film but the line
that with great power comes great
responsibility that's from the cop has
been in there through the years and so
when when you're a comic book fan and
you see that on the page and you see it
on the big screen it does something to
you I think in the same way the people
who read Hunger Games or were even like
familiar with Lord of the Rings from The
Source material you see it on the big
screen and it just it does something to
you that that it's never moved you like
that before well well first we get we
could talk about wakanda forever uh
being a great quote from Black Panther
it was so great they named the sequel
lacada forever but talking about
Spider-Man I agree I mean to hear hear
those words and I'm a big big Spider-Man
person I collected Comics uh my whole
life Spider-Man in particular but the
line that I love from those three Sam
Raimi movies between 2002 and 2007 at
the end of Spider-Man 2 which is my
all-time favorite comic book movie
when Mary change shows up at Peter
Parker's apartment and she's like I'm
here to save you and and he hears the
sirens and and Peter Parker turns to the
sirens and he looks back at MJ and she
says go get him tiger
that why just like oh my because because
the origination of go get em tiger like
that's the first time we've ever heard
go get him title in the comments I think
go get him tiger was around before okay
because that right thing she said it she
first of all Mary Jane in the comics see
the tiger all the time especially with
Peter Parker but he was a big Survivor
everyone was waiting like I was
especially waiting like why doesn't Mary
Jane ever call Peter Parker tiger in
these movies but Sam Remy was really
smart and that movie which was
co-written by Pulitzer Prize winner
Michael Shaban when I mean he saved it
for the moment that counted but the last
image of that movie is of a look of
concern on Mary Jane's face yeah this
thing might not work out yeah yeah yeah
relationship might be doomed when you
date a superhero Spider-Man 2 is a
masterpiece yeah I I'm not gonna call it
the first Transformers necessarily a
masterpiece but I will say Optimus Prime
the guy knows how to deliver a rousing
speech right and so when Optimus Prime
says something like fate really calls us
at the moment of our choosing you're
like oh okay this guy that senior quote
material it may not be the best movie or
the best franchise but that line sticks
with me pretty well I got one for you
okay I got one for you it was from the
best movie of 2022 the movie that should
have won the Oscar for Best Picture the
movie that brought people back to the
movies
very very very big way man 1.5 billion
dollars worldwide and saving the world a
movie I saw 12 freaking times in 2022.
talk to me Goose Top Gun Mavericks when
he's saying yeah that I was trying to
think of like the quote from Top Gun
Maverick and it may actually be
something that's typed because when MAV
is visiting with Iceman oh yeah and
Iceman can't speak it hurts him to talk
and so he's typing on his monitor
there's a lot of good stuff in that
exchange back and forth yeah I want to
talk about work right yeah right right
it's hard when you think about best
quotes not being best moments because I
had a hard time with that too best
scenes best interactions but just the
Standalone quotes we got to play by the
rules guys well okay let's we played by
the rules for the majority of this show
but before we say good night here I do
want to break the rules a little bit and
just open the floor to any other movie
quotes from any other era that you think
belong in the pantheon of your personal
favorite again this movie is rotten on
the Tomato Meter I think uh it's absurd
that it is but Young Guns Too when Billy
the Kid looks at this this poor sap and
he says Yoo-hoo I'll make you famous
whoa you talk what a line that is yeah
that's got a little bit of of sports
competitiveness for me where that's like
Michael Jordan looking at you and
thinking like oh I'm gonna watch what I
do watch how good I am at this game but
it also shows you the mindset ability of
the kid and that sold the movie in the
trailer when when Billy the Kid gets the
pistol out and says that it's like I
need to see what the hell's going on in
this movie I think that I know I
mentioned it earlier but uh it ain't
about how hard you hit that's like to me
the greatest quote Rocky obviously yeah
wow and like anything Balboa any any
quotes that are inspirational that you
want to put above your bed or like you
know when you wake up to look at it
those are the ones that even though
they're not the ones you quote in public
the most often the ones that you tell
yourself like a do or do not there is no
try or the one I tell you that is not a
movie quote but it's from Drew Bledsoe
to Tom Brady just sling it yeah totally
exactly I think a quote that actually is
very fitting considering there is now a
fifth Indiana Jones movie about to be
released in theaters
a lot of Trail work but I thought back
to the line from the first film
it's not the years it's the mileage
I picked out of him tried to save the
ark that movie is just talk about a
masterpiece right is it a lost ark did
you ever think you would live in a world
where Indiana Jones was listening to the
sympathy by the Devil by The Rolling
Stones not in a million years not in a
million years but man
this was so much fun just going through
all the okay last question here real
quick not as many horror movies as we
thought and so producer Brian and I were
talking about this and it's like there's
got to be other quotes from horror
movies all time horror movies is there
an all-time horror movie quote now some
people have this in a variety of
categories but when I grew up in
Williamsburg Virginia add video update
Jaws was always in the horror section
and so you're gonna need a bigger boat
there's got to be an all-time Club from
a horror movie that's a good one The
Shining has a few if you want to oh
here's Johnny yeah that's what I was
thinking about if you're taking if
you're going to look at a horror movie
that's also like one of the best sci-fi
movies I've ever made uh get away from
her you yes from Aliens yeah yeah
yes oh my God we could do this all day
I'm gonna be the Slime from that line
yeah yeah horror doesn't seem to be as
quotable in general because people died
yeah because people die and also the
standout moments are not quotes you get
one shot basically in a horror movie
like my favorite line from psycho is
not really a line but it's still it's in
there what is it the rain I'll never
attack oh there you go oh my God what
was that movie
no no no no no no no it was Michael
Douglas don't say a word don't say a
word yeah kick out someone yeah yeah but
it was very similar the way she was
acting to the way Samara moves out of
the way yeah well samar's the one who
sat in it so yeah Brittany Murphy yeah
there you go there you go got it all
right we'll go okay so we got some
hormones we love in there as well so uh
that is gonna do it for us let's quickly
go to mailbag Brian
[Music]
yeah we really could talk movie quotes
all day because they just keep popping
up we didn't even get to Caddyshack my
God you take drugs Danny every day good
good oh my God Argo yourself that's
a great one all right so this is from uh
ketchup crew member Steve iwerman you
can be like Steven email us anytime RT
is wrong at rottentomatoes.com and Steve
says Hey guys love the podcast I enjoyed
the episode on Super Mario Brothers from
1993 and sticking with the cartoon video
game genre what about the live-action
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles from 1990.
it's 41 rotten which I think is Criminal
and I'm inclined to agree with you there
Steve sought and loved it as a kid and
it still holds up today the action
scenes are pretty legit for 1990
especially considering how cumbersome
those Turtle suits had to be keep up the
good work Steve all right 1990 Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles can you give me a
quote from that movie not on your life
proxy no absolutely not are you kidding
me something about pizza Cowabunga
cowabunga right this is this is my issue
right now and I'll tell you guys what's
happening did you guys have recurring
nightmares as kids I still have a curry
nights four years about certain Turtles
yes fought crime they would come out of
the TV and they would kick the crap out
of me it was that through the windows
through the TV were those live action
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle looking
creepers and and I oh I hated them it
was a Raphael I wouldn't put it past him
it was all of them all those artists
they were coming through every single
place and my brother that knew that I
hated them so every birthday party
instead of doing Power Rangers you would
do turtles it just was such a nightmare
that I can't talk about them too long
all right well then I'll go with Master
Splinter when he said funny
um so I I love Turtle we should do that
soon on the show Steve thanks for that
um just wrapping things up here real
quick you could not have had two better
guests to talk movie quotes with than
Scott mance and Roxy's man where can
everybody out there finding all the cool
stuff you're working oh you know what
just follow me on Twitter and Instagram
at movie mans for all your movie
knowledge all your movie movie like
upcoming stuff especially I've been
quoting I've been posting a lot of stuff
about Star Trek because I just love
season three of Star Trek Picard and if
you are not watching season three of
Star Trek Picard on Paramount plus
you're missing out all right Roxy
Strider just adding yet another TV show
to her doctor you watched what 125 shows
yeah easy peasy I'll watch this in a day
yeah this is like please do yeah Child's
Play binge quick where can all the kids
out there find you when you're not
watching the tube everywhere at Roxy
Strayer and even while I'm watching the
two that's where I am you know keep up
with me there you can get a gold star
from us once again email us RT is wrong
at rottentomatoes.com anytime tell us
what movies we should be talking about
what lists on rottentomatoes.com like
the 25 most memorable movie lines from
the last 25 years should we cover TV
shows in there as well let us know your
thoughts RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com whatever your podcast
platform of choice asks you to do
subscribe rate review all that good
stuff do it for us because we keep
bringing you the best guests in the game
like a Scott Mance or and a Roxy strier
next week's episode I love when we get
to do these it's an after dark so you
never know what you're gonna get it's a
little bit looser we have some topics
that we get to eventually always with a
Primo guest so keep your eyes open for
that in the meantime four Roxy stryer
Scott Mance Brian Perez Remsen Allard
and everybody else here at the Rotten
Tomatoes family I am merely Mark Ellis
saying thank you good night and good
luck
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you